Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
As always, I'm your host David Flanagan,
also known across the internet as Rawkode. I'm
excited to be sharing with you today a
new project that no one has ever heard
of because it's not public yet.
So if you want to see a pretty
sweet project that can help you be more
productive and a happier developer,
you're at the right place. Building applications on
the dawn of cloud native has meant that
we don't just focus on our business logic
because our time is spread thin across ops,
DevOps, containers and message brokers, contracts, gRPC, GraphQL
and a myriad of a thousand other concerns.
But what if there was another way? What
if you could just focus on your business
logic and not have to worry about the
platform and just get shit done?
Well,
let me introduce you to Guidepad.
Guidepad is a framework that can get in
your face or get out your way. You
get to decide and what do I mean
by get in your face or get out
your way? Well, by get in your face
I mean that Guidepad can be opinionated.
It can provide tracks
that you just put your code on and
it run. You write a simple Python function
and ship it to prod with a git
push but if you want it to get
out your way you can use it as
a framework for deploying your code in your
applications to Kubernetes or even with Ansible.
The choice is yours. Today I'm going to
show you a small application that I built
on top of Guidepad the Guidepad way using
their type system, their services,
their data stores. Let's take a look. Okay,
so here we have my terminal
with two pins. The two pins aren't important
right now but they will be soon.
I built an application to resemble
Pocket.
If you're not familiar with Pocket, it's an
application where you can save web pages and
URLs that you will never ever read again.
I wanted to build the exact same thing
on top of Guidepad using Guidepad as the
framework. So the first thing we're going to
do is create a bookmark.
For this, I'm going to use the Guidepad
CLI.
Remember, we're doing this the Guidepad way with
only the Guidepad tooling, where I can say
entity
create
bookmark.
This command will allow me to take standard
n as a description of our bookmark.
We denote this with a dash and a
here dot. If you're familiar with Linux, you
have seen this syntax before.
I can now add our bookmark or I'm
just going to add the Rawkode Academy website.
We can then end our here doc like
so.
Now Guidepad here it does the plug in
stuff behind the scenes and we'll talk about
that as we progress through this video. But
all you need to know is right now
it's about to create a bookmark.
We can then use the Guidepad CLI to
list all of the bookmarks within the system.
So now I can do a Guidepad entity
list bookmark
and I'm going to pass in an empty
selector
because we have the ability to filter the
bookmarks if we wish. However, right now we
should only have one and my font's a
bit big but you can see we have
a whole bunch of information here, more than
the information that we provided on the command
line. Our Guidepad system
has taken the URL that we provided, it
has scraped the endpoint for metadata
and found us a title, a description,
the language of the web page, it's tried
to find an author and an image but
that's not important and then there's a summary
on the end. So what happened here?
Well we have deployed a plugin to Guidepad
or the bookmark service that tells it whenever
you save and you bookmark go and fetch
all this information and update the entity,
even use an OpenAI to generate a summary
of the web page. So let's try that
one more time with another URL.
With the Guidepad
entity
create,
click for, here doc URL
and a story from the BBC. End our
here doc and let our entity be created
by the Guidepad system.
And done. Now we can run Guidepad
entity list
bookmark,
and we can even filter this now if
we wish.
Let's say that we only want to see
the URL
that we just added.
Let's scroll up. This article has Elon Musk
and Mark Zuckerberg agree to hold a cage
fight. We have the description. We have the
language.
And because this was an article from the
BBC, we do have an author. However, there's
still no image. And we have our summary
from ChatGPT.
Perfect. Let's take a look at how we
built a system on top of Guidepad. Let's
head over to my IDE where we have
a directory called Guidepad Rawkode.
This is my Guidepad plugin. A Guidepad plugin
is a bunch of Python code which you
store and get and register with the Guidepad
system. You may have noticed that every time
I ran the Guidepad CLI,
it was fetching the plugins and the types
doing constant reconciliation
or looking for changes within the Git repository.
You get to define your own requirements dot
text for each of your plugins. So here,
it was very easy for me just to
add in the OpenAI
package as well as b print to make
my debugging life a little bit easier. Then
we have another directory again called Guidepad Rawkode
where we can define and work with a
type system provided to us by Guidepad.
In order to provide my plugin, I had
to tell it the operations, the services, and
the types that my plugin is going to
register. What you'll see here is I actually
have two systems being deployed by a single
plugin. I haven't just written a pocket bookmark
API, I've also written a URL shortener which
maybe we'll take a look at in another
video, but right now let's take a look
at our bookmark type.
This is a very simple Python class that
extends the Guidepad base type system. Not important
that you understand how this works right now,
so let's just go over the high levels.
We define the properties for our bookmarks.
One we need a URL,
then all of the additional fields that we're
going to try to extract from the URL
itself such as the title, description, the language
and so forth. All of the columns
that you seen on the CLI.
We then have a bunch of functions that
I provided to make my life a little
bit easier.
One, a function which will get the body
for the URL. This is just using the
Python request module where we do a get
on the URL that was provided. If it
doesn't return us to a hundred, we don't
allow you to save your URL. Let's check
that out.
Let's do Guidepad
entity,
create bookmark
where we have a URL
google.com/fatepage
and end. And there we have our exception.
Now is this the best way to block
the saving of the bookmark?
No, not really, however it does work and
in the future we'll take a look at
how to handle errors properly within the Guidepad
system. We then have our summarize function which
will grab the first twelve thousand characters of
the web page and send them to chat
GPT for a completion and a summary. In
order to enrich our bookmarks with metadata we're
using the micro link API. We send it
the URL and request the metadata. From here
we can just set the properties on our
class title,
description, language and so forth and the way
that we make this work is to override
the save function on the base type. So
here we just say if there is no
title meaning we haven't fetched any metadata before
or perhaps it failed,
then we grab the body,
enrich with metadata
and summarize.
Nice and simple.
So there's a lot to like about this
file. One, I haven't really had to use
any of the Guidepad APIs.
I just wrote Python code. The one time
I did use the Guidepad API was to
handle something that I really don't wanna have
to worry about, that I really don't want
to have to handle myself which is secrets.
If we scroll up you'll see here on
line 31 that we used
secret dot list single to request an OpenAI
token. This reveals something about Guidepad that may
not have been obvious at first. Everything in
Guidepad is built on the type system including
secrets,
bookmarks or types, short URLs or types, services
or types,
ingress or types, everything is built on the
system. So when you buy into that opinionated
system,
building applications can almost become trivial. You get
to focus on your business logic
and none of the surrounding platform infrastructure
or operating needs.
Okay, but let's assume we don't want to
have to rely on the Guidepad entity list
bookmarks to see the bookmarks within our system.
It's likely that you want to be able
to consume them from external services, third party
systems or even applications on your mobile phone
or your desktop. Well, we can do that
too. If I run curl and grab this
last command,
you can see that we can curl Rawkode
launchpads dev or dw tech blah blah blah
bookmark API two. This is a domain provided
by the Guidepad service
that exposes my bookmark API,
and this is the second time I've done
it. Go figure. But if we run this,
we can now see the two bookmarks
that I created at the start of this
video. You can see the Rawkode Academy and
Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk agreeing to fight.
So in order to make this work,
we had to define a service. Let's pop
open our plug in and open our plug
in dot py. Here you can see that
we expose the Bitmark API as a service
on this plug in. This Bitmark API extends
the operations API within Guidepad.
The operations API allows you to define operations
available to query data within the Guidepad system.
Here we're extending that remove a whole bunch
of boilerplate that would otherwise be required to
expose a flask application on the Guidepad framework.
Again, buying in to the Guidepad
tracks so that we don't have to do
everything ourselves. The only thing that's important in
this file is that we give a service
type a name, something that uniquely identifies it
within the Guidepad system. We then tell it
that the endpoints for this API are provided
by my plugin operations
bookmark. Let's head over there. We open the
operations directory and we go to the bookmarks
file. Here we're using the blueprint flask functionality
to provide new endpoints on our API. Here
we can see that on slash we are
going to list bookmark
and we're using the Guidepad
base type APIs
to fetch those resources. Here we call bookmark
dot list with no filters,
we use a comprehension to loop over them
and we serialize them giving us back the
bookmarks object, which we can then turn into
JSON and return.
It's just that simple.
So as a bit of an experiment why
don't we add a new piece of functionality
to this application. Let's copy our list function
like so and this time we're gonna add
a to do endpoint which is going to
return all of the bookmarks that we haven't
read yet. We'll call this to do bookmarks.
So we don't want to return all bookmarks
here, we only want to return the ones
where red equals false.
So we can add a search
like so.
However,
we want to do
no. We want red
as false.
Now this property doesn't exist on our type
yet, so let's make that change. Okay, so
let's add a red property to our bookmark
type.
Here we can set the default equals
false,
meaning that by default, if there is no
property, we assume it is unread or no
value at least. So let's deploy this change
to the Guidepad system. To do that, we
go back to our terminal where we could
do git add
Guidepad Rawkode
and git commit
beat add
to do endpoint and push. Okay. Now that
we've pushed that up, we can run Guidepad,
entity, list,
bookmark, all bookmarks. However, this time we're only
gonna request a few of the attribute.
First, the URL,
whether it's been read,
and then the summary,
like so. Now because we pushed our plug
in to a remote repository
and now we're running the Guidepad CLI, it's
going to notice that we need to update
the plug in. Do we get pull, check
the requirements
and then we'll have our plug in up
to date. So we also added with the
latest change our new endpoint
pull down any bookmarks that we haven't read
yet. We can run a curl pasting in
the URL for our service and add our
new to do endpoint and pipe it through
a JQ. This returns both of our bookmarks
because both are currently set to false and
unread.
So let's go up to this top pane.
Now I could do a Guidepad entity
edit bookmark and drop in this ID,
but I'm just going to create a new
one from a file so you can see
that flow and then that'll show us that
we have a working filtered API endpoint on
the bottom tab too. So we could do
entity create
bookmark and instead of using the hair dot,
we're gonna pull this in from our plugin
bookmark dot JSON
like so. We can pop over into my
editor and you'll see that this bookmark.JSON
just has a URL and the red status
set to true. So let's run our summary
one more time.
Nice
and if we query our to do endpoint
we still have two bookmarks even though above
we have google.com
read true. So that's Guidepad.
Guidepad is an extremely flexible, powerful, opinionated tool
all at the same time. You get to
opt in to the behaviors that you want.
If you just want to write some code,
have it deployed and exposed to your customers,
don't have to worry about databases, you could
do that. Join us for the next video
where we take a slightly different approach to
Guidepad. We'll see you then. Have a great
day.